hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
problems that arise is fairly frequently
in relation to friendships and other
relationships in our real day-to-day
lives is something that Aristotle will
talk about in terms of wood might call
the demands of multiple relationships we
get into cases where we can't actually
satisfy everybody we can't we can't do
what we think that we want to or provide
what we would like to give back to
everybody who were involved with and so
the question is who do we owe wat to
another way to think about this is what
sort of ordering of priorities do we
establish to decide between the
legitimate claims of various people in
our life we may not in fact be able to
satisfy all of them and one of the
things that Aristotle tells us it's very
important about this is that we cannot
define precise rules he actually uses
the term Orion which means to define to
date you know set up literally limits or
our borders we don't have the capacity
to create sort of like a checklist that
would work in every single case now
there are a lot of you know you might
say codes of morality out there that
will sometimes detail years where
first duty lies here through second duty
lies here's what you owe to each person
but the problem with that is that they
love and end up being quite inflexible
and sometimes actually going against
reason so we see a lot of clashes
between you know one way of trying to
resolve this and then what the demands
of the specific situation are there
could be some real unfairness that
happens Aristotle solution it is quite
interesting the first thing that he
tells us is that there is no one single
person who is in every single case
entitled to be given first priority so
you know that's going to make things
difficult to begin with there there
could be certain areas in which we have
to give certain people first priority
for example you know in terms of my
child school my children get first
priority as far as I'm concerned well
you know what if my child ends up
bullying another child do I stick up for
my kid against the principal and say who
are you to tell my kid what to do that
would actually make me a bad parent so
in that case I have to take the side of
the the other kid I have a
responsibility there and you can say
well that's just a matter of ethics and
not necessarily a matter of friendship
or relationships but it could indeed be
a matter of relationships my kid bullies
the kid who lives next door it was a
neighbor who I actually like how do I
handle this do I say my child right or
wrong or do I way things differently you
might actually say that what my kid is
entitled to that cases is being told hey
knock it off or I'm going to punish it
but this is a very important thing no
one single person is entitled to be
number one in every single case and the
upshot of that is when people try to
tell us that they have to be treated as
number one in every single case from
Aristotle's perspective that should be a
red flag we should be saying there's
something wrong with this issue
patient we need to think long and hard
about whether we want to continue to be
friends in the same way with this person
jealousy very often works like that
doesn't it the person insists that they
have to be placed front and center or
else you don't really love them you
don't really care about them the ends
even in business relationships you know
one person insists that they have to be
you know taken into account before all
the other clients now that that's a
problem now aerosol does give us a
general rule but it's woman has
exceptions so what is the general rule
he says that we should return services
prior to doing additional things for
other people who you know like for
example our friends the ones that we
hang out with their comrades is because
of the hetalia right we should undertake
we should we should make good on our
obligations that we already have before
engaging of limited resources in time
than we have with with somebody else so
if I have been laxing and actually
getting back in touch with my friends in
the area who are waiting for me to
reciprocate on inviting them to dinner
after they've invited me to dinner I
should not be going out and seeking out
somebody else they have dinner with
before them I should make good on that
if I owe a letter to somebody I should
spend the time writing that letter
rather than emailing somebody else who
is new who isn't already connected with
me and we could go on and on and on a
lot of times people will favor one one
person whether it's their other lover or
spouse couldn't both by the way their
mentor the protege they're very close
friend their sibling their parents their
child over the the rightful claims that
other people have already placed upon
them and here are some pics of depth
that's this wrong now one of the
interesting except
yes is this case of being ransom one of
the problems that did arise in ancient
Greece was there were what we call
hunters embed kidnappers and they would
kidnap you and hold you for ransom right
some areas were particularly prone to
that's where there were pirates who
would like to hold people for ransom and
make money that way Arizona says who do
you have this obligation to you get
ransomed by somebody now your father and
that person both get taken by pirates at
the same time you only have enough money
to ransom one of them who do you ransom
before the other who did who is a wonder
you ransom you ransom the one who
actually you know already incurred are
you incurred a debt with them by them
ransom in you should you respond it in
turn or should you ransom your father
first good question there now you might
say what you already owe your father so
much more than you could possibly
provide it with so that you should favor
this Arizona doesn't actually you know
give you a one time for all solution to
this he just proposes it as a moral
dilemma that you want to think about
another set of examples that we could
think about more generally it is where
there are demands of nobility the Tokai
loan right something is fine something
is noble that may override this right or
necessity you know you you are placed in
a crisis situation if you don't act
right now human lives are going to be
lost or so much property is going to be
lost that it's going to lead to you know
terrible life for everybody else you
have to act and that's doing you know
something for other people rather than
following throughout the obligations
that you already have great example of
that sort of thing would be that
consider you know what goes on in
companies when there is something going
on that might require some whistle
blowing right you you know if you
good benefits packages maybe you know
your friend wants you to look the other
way but there is kind of a necessity or
there's a moral mobility involved in
following through on telling the truth
about what's actually happen maybe it's
whistle blowing about environmental
impact on a vulnerable community right
somebody being poisoned I know aerosol
says to go on with this that we owe
different things to different people and
he has a nice discussion of this he says
here we go it would be felt that our
parents have the first claim on us for
maintenance since we owe it to him as a
debt and support the authors of our ba
stands before self-preservation moral
mobility honor is also dude appearance
as it is to be God's though not
indiscriminate honor you don't hold the
same honor to one's father is to one's
mother nor they honor due to a great
philosopher or a gentle well you order
your father the honor appropriate to a
father which one's mother that which is
appropriate to her so we already have a
set of different obligations to
different people based on what their
role and their relationship does he says
we should also pay to our seniors the
honor due to their age by for example
rising when they enter offering them a
seat and so on towards comrades and
brothers he outlines a different set of
obligations we should use frankness of
speech parecia we should actually tell
them how things are whereas as parents
maybe we we we soft-pedal little bit we
don't necessarily call mom and dad on
their nonsense because of their mom and
dad but with brother and sister we say
hey you're screwing up what do what are
you doing there right it says we should
share all of our possessions with them
kinsmen also fellow tribesmen fellow
citizens the rest to all we must always
endeavor to render their do comprising
there are several claims in respective
relationship and a virtue or utility so
you see there's a number of different
bases here that we have to kind of
juggle so to speak and that can be point
that's why we don't have precise rules
for this he also says that this is where
what will fit a shot with this when the
people are similar in relationship like
we're talking about two people that were
friends with in terms of pleasure and
one say is an older friend and one is a
newer friend or one is a friend who also
has some virtue going for them the other
one doesn't it's fairly easy to decide
in those cases how we should prioritize
at least for a person who is a good
practical reason it becomes more
difficult because he says when the
people that are connected to us are in
different types of relationships with us
so how do we reconcile the obligations
to our parents and to our friends and to
our spouse sometimes that can get or to
our work colleagues right start mixing
in all these different people all these
different considerations and values it
starts to get rather tricky and it
requires a lot of looking at the
specific situation and making sense of
that that is where the virtue the
intellectual virtue of phronesis or
practical wisdom becomes particularly
important in part because we don't have
any hard and fast rules and that's
precisely where furnaces and yours in
and helps us up so this is a real issue
that Aristotle is grappling with your an
issue that all of us have to face at one
time or another and one that is not
going to go away and so he provides us
with some useful advice about this